this week we've got puddle fun chemical
lattes and zonkey what's the song it's
like a donkey that goes on I don't know
zebra donkey right jump I jumped it
that's pretty [ __ ] good man we said
two really dumb things over here honky
zombie that's a great point dude it's
just a regular zombie our first story
there's this driver of a construction
company van who kept slip splashing
pedestrian because I love splashes on
purpose on purpose
Oh like in the movies where they drive
by the gutter think he's an [ __ ] but
funny [ __ ]
oh he records this know someone was in
front of them yeah recording it yeah
here we go oh he's pulling off to this
side oh my god he's doing that [ __ ] on
purpose Ziggy is sagging yeah
where's this at so that's one you know
what's funny I'm actually honest Tim I'm
like another person another person this
guy's like a misunderstood hero right
there wasn't enough water what a
[ __ ] do that is so this is the grand
theft auto life yeah
okay my toes are curling because it's
wet and I think he's gonna [ __ ] slit
and kill somebody
oh I gotta go fast you know and he's
like swerving you know what I pictured
is him hitting that and then hitting a
parked car that'd be amazing Karma
yeah so this camera caught him splashing
three sets of pedestrians and so this
video was reported to a police officer
oh why did you do it against the law
what super dangerous driving I mean
that's like if they're legal precedents
for this like no splashing yeah yeah
don't but you didn't you never heard of
code [ __ ] don't be a [ __ ] oh don't
be a dick what's that for four five what
is that police come three six seven yeah
we got a three six seven in Brian's been
such a dick right now you could be on
television doing that oh yeah totally
there's the one dude who's the [ __ ]
narc you're that police voice the
walkie-talkie voice he's calling you a
[ __ ] he said you're a narc who I'm not
not a Mike a narc do you look like
you're gonna steal to take our cocaine
okay thank you [ __ ] party pooper
that's fine but yeah so this so the
company that owns that van they ended up
issuing an apology on Facebook and
saying that that driver has been
terminated and he lost his job I hope
you learned a [ __ ] valuable lesson
you [ __ ] back what if his passion is to
like own a water park yeah he was just
trying to he was wasting his time and of
the money so this was his part-time gig
you know and welcome to comedy dude do
one joke you lose your job now right
that guy made me laugh that was funny
man eyes are work so if it happened to
you you get splashed right you'd like
you're wearing your best shirt awesome
I've been on this planet for a long time
I know when it rains don't stand next to
the curb Oh beats far back as you can if
someone's gonna splash you yeah it's my
first barbecue I don't walk in the rain
yeah I stay home where yes where is this
in Canada oh come on if someone did that
to me though like I think I would start
busting up like crazy I think so
[ __ ] good one dad I don't know
because it was huge those waves were
like here you could surf in that [ __ ]
yeah I think I'm almost 100% I would
laughs yeah you saw the guy with the
umbrella he was yet an umbrella and it
just went whoosh especially if I had an
umbrella and it was a tidal wave I might
offer you got me good I would Captain
America that [ __ ] just put the shield
right up cover my set out and I think
the satyr the day the funnier it is yeah
now this was winter you might like
freeze to death so it looked like it was
like well during a warm time so there's
no harm no foul in July yeah because
this is like the adult version of
getting pants you know pads like the
adult version like you don't you can't
pants anybody more cuz it's sexual
harassment freak to splash someone ah
those are the good old day it kind of
reminds me when I was at a CRC like it's
a Community College my sacramental you
should get like crazy winds and crazy
rain and there's always like these
little Asian girls with umbrellas but
right when the wind would pick up you
would drag them across this is hilarious
Bend okay and happy when they weren't
chucks there's no grip so just because
it's just flat smooth concrete and
[ __ ] just [ __ ] feets and we just
don't nobody does anything we just watch
that's amazing to watch that happened to
we're saying how far she can go when I
throw dice too at the same time just
without the umbrella like sometimes
there's really strong wind and I'll just
be trying to walk against the oh my god
damn and I like pushed a little bit
blown down by wind the windy streets of
a hybrid you know windy alhambra gets
where we need streets are down ease on
down I never know there is that video
though what are you going tight in that
typhoon oh yeah that should look
hilarious like they were holding the
[ __ ] pole and [ __ ] yeah that was
funny I like those [ __ ] uh news
reporters that try to like rough it out
next to tornado oh yeah let it ride
hello Johnson leading out the side of
their face and they're still committed
to it I'm always thinking what's the
point of that because it's hilarious I'm
pretty sure it's just because it's funny
yeah I think it's a hazing they're like
[ __ ] send the newbies out there
there's like a video you could probably
find on YouTube this guy's legit trying
to do it as he's at a 45 degree angle do
you see the video where the guy from
Mexico they're just like the concert
yeah everything it's like it's like
Wizard of Oz when the house gets picked
up and thrown around it's like all these
tents are in the air it's [ __ ] crazy
and he still deliver in the news
no he I don't know what he's doing but
it was hilarious it's funny cuz he was
spinning as he was like talking and then
like everything was [ __ ] spinning
around like Mexican Lollapalooza yeah
you know what I thought that was I
thought it was like a refugee camp or
something that got hit what a tornado
cuz there were so many tents just in the
air it looked crazy
well California's got fire tornadoes
have you seen that oh yeah yeah yeah
yeah I and our rents the same I think
when we get fire tornadoes we should get
like $200 off our energies
what's a fire tornado it's like a
tornado made of fire you mean like the
in the forest fire yeah what is it out
at Culver City where no it's like you
always have those forest fires every
year like in the remember that big one
that happened yeah yeah yeah what's
going on right now
thousands of acres all right bird night
story there was this pregnant woman that
was served a cleaning solution oh man in
her cup instead of a latte
wait where was it at though they were
trying to kill her how did you know
MacDonald yeah it's the same [ __ ]
stripper too huh did a Russian spy or
something no so this took place in
Canada Canada Canton is where that girl
took a poop and then just threw it after
high at the Tim Hortons but the most
amazing part of that is how the Poochie
Kratz it it's like a boomerang it
doesn't break up or anything did you see
that one yeah we saw it here tell me the
new Florida a new Florida her poop was a
little mushy - I remember that damn
what's going on what is it to me white
people
Canadians she's hot yeah so here's they
try to kill a hot girl it's rude
a pregnant lady she's a pretty lady oh
she looks so angry and [ __ ] cuz I love
but that's just a regular photo that's
not at the McDonald's maybe this is like
for the the article articles the
photographer always goes look angry yeah
look look outraged you call him a
photographer
he says y'all give cousin frittata very
target it's a dog photographer okay but
yes so this was the cleaning agent that
was still attached to the coffee machine
so it's a coffee machine cleaning
solution do she's gonna win so much
money so much cash yeah so with the baby
okay cuz this is a double whammy it
could have just been a lady but it was a
pregnant woman yeah whoa talk about
lucky yeah so this woman her name is
Sarah she was taking her son to a
baseball term was she dumb enough to
drink it well she took a sip out of it
cuz they had the lid she took a sip and
that's what she realized what the hell
so she immediately spit it out she and
Jess
oh thank god and she pulled over cuz she
was driving and then she rinse out her
mouth with the water oh good smart woman
yes so then she drove back to the
McDonald's demanded to speak to a
manager but there was only supervisor
there and they told her they apologize
profusely and they were just saying like
this will never happen again but she
still didn't feel like that was enough
cuz she did get her money refunded
obviously yeah how many other people
[ __ ] got the coffee - you don't even
know there could have been like like a
senior citizen that died
you can still she's definitely not Asian
dude cuz an Asian person would have
drank the whole thing and that would
have been like there's something wrong
with this there's all bad he doesn't
like and then we could play all the way
home yeah something's wrong with it yeah
which is coffee I don't know damn man oh
yeah imma go back I can't waste food if
I paid for I'm gonna finish it
yeah for sure even you know wouldn't get
it [ __ ] it man let's do this [ __ ]
acid-base solution though I've done
worse I'm your inside I wonder how bad
it was though good daddy's coffee as
prison cuz I do that like I'll drink
half the coffee even if the first sip
was nasty then like meh something's
wrong with water from the restaurant you
ever get it word taste and smell like
soap still cuz he did all just like wish
that it will go away now drink half of
it I'll be like I gotta ask for another
cup or I'll try to get a straw cuz it's
better if you get a straw I won't it
won't taste so bad or ask them for lemon
to make the soap go away sometimes you
don't know if it's the drink or if it's
you you know I like when you brush your
teeth in everything tastes weird so
sometimes you just have a restaurant or
like wait is it me it's you yeah they're
proving the [ __ ] Asian after you eat
it or like oh I think no I was a
restaurant this time yeah yeah for sure
they [ __ ] up yeah cuz I know you don't
know she's gonna own her own McDonald
cell right I mean that's pretty much how
much money she gonna get really suing a
white she's not gonna shoot that's how
nice Canadians are very nice
she wanted to do is just to share her
story and that's what she contacted me
share your story to a lawyer yeah she
wants Instagram followers they might
have caps on like what do you call it
[ __ ] a judgments how much they can sue
for certain things we don't have that so
there's got to be a precedent of if
you're pregnant drinking acid this is
how much money you could sue for maybe I
don't know cuz the lady who got scalded
her [ __ ]
she was the one that she called you know
she scalded her vag a copy yeah are you
sure was a vagina it was her it was the
top it was like the thigh mom's like her
Mons pubis what do you call it yeah you
the top of the area right there she
burned it the the she pouring coffee on
average on her clothes yeah it was that
hot yeah it was like second-degree burns
or some yeah there's actually you can
see the photos the article like like cuz
people kind of go oh I can't believe you
sued McDonald's for a cup of coffee but
back then there was no temperature thing
to it so it was scorching [ __ ] hot
because of the what do you call it like
they just heated the [ __ ] out of it like
boilie yeah so then when it opened up
and it spilled all over her clothes and
everything it actually burned her
but it wasn't because it was like oh you
burned my lips yeah it was like
devastation yeah so if you see all of it
then you go all that is pretty [ __ ] up
because the way that people tell the
story is like can you believe this
greedy [ __ ] [ __ ] sued McDonald's for
like just getting some hot coffee but it
[ __ ] her up pretty bad yeah now they
they're saying that they took up a
health inspector visited the McDonald's
and they're not gonna have a furtherance
and investigation cuz apparently
everything else is just like that one
small mistake of them still leaving the
cleaning could've been adjust honest
mistake [ __ ] half done yeah that never
would have happened in America though I
feel worse would have happened because
all the times in California specifically
all the Mexicans broke into McDonald's
and they keep that [ __ ] perfect dude
they're careful next kids are careful
huh they're hella careful did I never
went to a [ __ ] Mexican McDonald's
with it you're the tall sex
never seen by the way how many Mexicans
have you seen that I live in LA I see
all the tons of Mexicans they're like
hobbits they just get smaller and
smaller Mexican small then we're not the
same people
so to Central America they get shorter
it's Mexican to Mexican
oh you're Mexican as well she looks like
what you thought she was Romanian I
thought she was like he does look like
him you look tie
hi-yah Oh like a [ __ ] yeah like you
like you she's Wonder Boy woman is now
I'm sure that porno is out there so
magic dick yeah yeah you're just hating
cuz my bigs probably bigger than the
both of you probably so pretty that's
why okay thank you
and we're back we're good again he
always knows how to reset it yeah that
was perfect all right for our last story
this Egyptian zoo Oh donkey yep they
have zoos in Egypt
yeah they've just opened why wouldn't
they are they all desert animals yeah
that's got to suck man if you're a polar
bear and you got a living you went to
Egypt right no okay never mind
oh it's a merabh that's what I thought
too that you would the Egypt cashews on
a camel is more you want culture just
wine I [ __ ] swear it man I saw a
camel I assumed Egypt I'm sorry I did
too though I upon the other side of
North Africa I don't know where North
Africa is What's in between Egypt and
Morocco Algeria or something or
something like that
there's something in between it's
another camel land yeah there's that one
the Gaddafi land Libya Libya Gaddafi one
of my favorite SS like Dali land like
Dolly Parton theme park yeah
you ride a roller coaster you get
decapitated you know how like Libya
Algeria Tunisia I was right oh I'd
forgot Tunisia anyway so this let me
show you guys some photos on or anything
but Africa is a hard continent to
remember in terms of what yeah like all
the country where they are oh yeah
there's that be more than 30 countries
do most of you couldn't tell you where
all the states are in the United States
let alone countries in Africa that's
true I know California in California
what do they do pain a donkey zebra
colors exactly what they did
oh I mean really bad so we're getting
interracial you know what he's [ __ ]
zebra that's what I thought
[ __ ] that racist ass donkey do [ __ ]
Chinese eyes he looks like ms-13 of
animals right to where are our donkeys
already inner interspecies or is it
mules are mules are mules are donkey
horse mix hybrids right and Endor
sterile yeah okay but then donkeys are
donkeys mules are like the Blake
Griffin's of the animal kingdom that
confirmed that the animal could not be a
zebra because zebras have dark snouts
and small pointed ears and that one that
has a life one out with long rounded
ears they try to pull a fast one at the
zoo they're like we don't have any
zebras so they just painted a donkey but
the zoo's director is denying anything
nah this is a Libra yeah what's he gonna
say what else is he gonna say unless
that zebra got unless they've gone
they've got tagged by gangbangers right
those stripes are hella bad though
that's a baby zebra it's a cute a zebra
well I mean it looks good like the paint
job looks nice it looks like it's sad
rodeo
even he doesn't believe the dude got
runny mascara like a drag queen I know
he's been crying all day yeah what do
they do spray paint the donkey like
primer and then paint how did they do
that honestly these stripes don't look
that bad it's just in the face he looks
home barest you mean you know they do
that with [ __ ] Chow dogs they do a
panda they do panda poo yeah Chow Chow
dogs
that's probably animal save I'm pretty
sure this is just a [ __ ] it's
breaking yeah just gotta be the woman
like you ever seen like world's worst
prisons that's gonna be like zoos for
these animals
ride like the worst Sue's out there like
they got a they get all these different
cheap like barn animals like turkeys and
they go come [ __ ] see the giraffe
yeah see the ostrich yeah see the
ostriches it's a turkey that they
painted yeah do this like that is like
the ladyboys of the animal animal
kingdom yeah like it looks like a girl
but it's got a dick like a drag queen
show but for animals yeah damn dude
that's [ __ ] up yeah it's kind of funny
though yeah oh your pain but I'm
laughing yeah yeah but I don't know
they're still sticking like they're
saying no that's a zebra oh he's like
that's like one of those people they
just get caught in a lie and they just
have to stick just stick we love it
though they guy they stick to their guns
man like pretty [ __ ] good what is
that I kind of want to see all the other
animals they made yeah have you guys
been in the LA Zoo or the one off the
five yeah yeah I've been there
actually they're like legit animals in
there yeah it looks kind of sad though
[ __ ] tragic racing for animal yeah
when I was a kid I think cuz for some
reason I just picture like just like
East LA dude like tour guide just walks
you through the place it's small though
like every animal is like little things
oh oh yeah it was some men over here we
have a pigeon to the left we have a
raccoon you know like you
man like animal like everybody says zoos
treat animals like [ __ ] but you know
treats animals worse in zoos mother
nature it's like what's the crime rate
in the forest man that's the murder rate
the jungle it's like 100 percent yeah
yeah zoo they're guaranteed life
yeah and food but in nature they could
be killed every day it's like it's a bad
neighborhood out there all they got yeah
that's true I'd rather be like I'd
rather have kids point and laugh at me
every day and I get fed and I'm safe
then like worried about my life animal
plants like saw for animals dude
everything's getting either murdered or
[ __ ] Oh
okay sometimes in that order that's all
they show is just murder and [ __ ] I
like it when they dramatize it too
thought the [ __ ] no like the [ __ ]
it's kind of like a soap opera because
they'll don't have like like the
meerkats and then the leader and then
like what's all yeah like they're trying
to hunt but then there's this one that's
hungry and I had that one British dude
in the background doing the voice-over
yeah I like those
[Music]